[Musique]
le mag au coeur du Salon International
de l'Agriculture et des Sion 2023
bonjour et bienvenue à tous cette
émission est une première et nous emmène
au plus près et aux côtés des
agriculteurs et producteurs de la
Réunion qui ont fait le déplacement
exprès de la Réunion jusqu'ici à Paris
pour venir rencontrer le public et les
consommateurs ils sont venus faire la
promotion de l'excellence de leur
savoir-faire de leurs produits et c'est
une course qui est lancée une course
dont le coup d'envoi a été donné
officiellement ce matin par le Président
de la République Emmanuel Macron a
ouvert le bas et des différentes
personnalités qui viendront déambuler
dans les allées du salon le village
réunion en picard est prêt 800 mètres
carrés 32 exposants ces hommes et ces
femmes sont venus des quatre coins de
nuit présentation Sophie Roger
des couleurs de l'ambiance des saveurs
en 2023 le village réunion augmente sa
surface 800 mètres carrés installés
cette année au deuxième étage du
pavillon 5 du Parc des Expositions Porte
de Versailles
répartis sur cette îlot de 100 mètres
carrés chacun les exposants réunionnais
gagnent du terrain pour capter
l'attention du public
en fait ça on a obligé de le faire à la
maison on le trouve pas en bocal en
général donc on a mis en Brocal
justement pour pouvoir que son boulot le
soir même la Réunion comme dit Bada de
son travail pour le temps de faire
gagner
que la dégustation pour tenter le public
au cœur du salon le chef Sébastien
Catherine cuisine tous les jours sucré
le matin salé l'après-midi
le producteur normalement il doit se
baigner sur le stand là on va discuter
avec lui pour savoir avec comment il
produit quels sont quel est son produit
favori cette année qu'est-ce qui veut
mettre à l'honneur et après on essaie de
travailler avec différents producteurs
différents produits et différents façons
de décliner le produit par exemple à la
en l'occurrence dans la pâtisserie avec
une crème à la vanille et ben il y aura
d'autres produits qu'on pourra mettre en
soirée en sucre
et on sent bien l'aspect professionnel
du produit
la Réunion
le temps le soleil tu as tout ça
des saveurs aussi tous les jours de la
musique de l'isea le coup d'envoi du
salon et haut en couleur et s'annonce
prometteur
[Musique]
le Salon International de l'Agriculture
forte aussi des enjeux institutionnels
Monsieur Serge warroux bonjour vous êtes
premier bis président du conseil
départemental des legal agriculture et
aux Affaires européennes
vous avez pu
hier soir à cette rencontre à ce moment
dédié entre délégation de la Réunion et
Emmanuel Macron parce qu'il en est
ressorti délégation de l'outre-mer et le
président Emmanuel Macron qui a rappelé
deux problématiques majeures la première
problématique phytosanitaire et la
problématique de la souveraineté
alimentaire s'agissant de la
problématique phytose sanitaire le
président de la République a bien
conscience que la France est partie plus
loin que les directives européennes et
qu'il était prêt à revenir sur cette
position en disant qu'il faut maintenant
mettre en place un plan de sortie de
certaines molécules parler de plan de
sortie ça vaut le dire tout simplement
avant de sortir un produit trouver une
solution alternative pour nos
agriculteurs pour qu'ils continuent à
entretenir leur champ et à produire
s'agissant de la problématique de la
souveraineté alimentaire il n'a fait que
confirmer ce qui avait été annoncé le 25
octobre 2019 à Lille la réunion à petit
île à grandance en particulier tout
simplement parce que on voit bien que
lorsqu'on a vécu les crises sanitaires
les crises mondiales il est important
que chaque territoire puisse produire
pour sa population mais on parle bien de
souveraineté alimentaire et non pas
d'autonomie alimentaire pourquoi si je
prends l'exemple de la Réunion quand on
parle de céréales nous ne pouvons pas
être en autonomie alimentaire nous
restons dépendants mais par contre
souveraineté alimentaire c'est sur
l'ensemble des produits qu'on retrouve
dans la cuisine locale les grains verts
là et l'oignon les tomates et tout ce
qui fait qu'on a besoin pour manger à la
Réunion on a parlé des légumes mais
aussi de la viande
de façon globale quelles sont les
attentes portées par ce salon édition de
mes 23 pour le marché je crois que on
vient confirmer je dirais les bons
résultats que nous avons obtenus ces
dernières années on sait que maintenant
on a un public qui nous attend et pour
nos exposants c'est aussi une chance je
vois que on a aussi augmenté le nombre
d'exposants deux exposants
supplémentaires pour la Réunion on va
mettre en avant les produits classiques
je dirais mais le miel de la Réunion
c'est la première fois qu'il est présent
on a aussi le chocolat la vanille reste
bien évidemment un produit froid et nous
avons tous les produits qui sont des
produits d'entrée de d'entrée des fruits
qui sont là par exemple et quelque part
on vient vendre le savoir-faire de nos
agriculteurs de nos agricultrices et le
100% réunion est aussi présent sur ce
salon parce qu'on veut montrer
véritablement que notre savoir-faire
aujourd'hui est reconnu et que le
département de La Réunion à travers les
pays 2030 décline aujourd'hui ses
orientations en action
c'est moi qui vous remercie
le village Réunion étant tout cas déjà
très prisé des visiteurs alors nous nous
sommes mêlés à la foule pour recueillir
leurs impressions
[Musique]
bien sympathique le rhum arrangé à
toutes les sauces là c'est très bon et
le monsieur est très gentil et il va
nous emmener à la Réunion
il est très bon on sent bien
derrière moi je suis convaincu il est
très bon et très réussi
c'est une belle découverte c'est
excellent en plus les produits sont
commercialisés via internet on peut les
commander très intéressant
[Musique]
le mag au cœur du Salon international de
l'agriculture c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui rendez-vous demain
[Musique]